another deadly storm is slamming the
West right now there have been blizzard
conditions in California Sierra Nevada
mountains several feet of snow have
already fallen in a region buried in
snow from last week roads are blocked
tens of thousands have lost power and
many people are now trapped in their
homes Jonathan bigliotti is in the
Sierra east of Sacramento Jonathan good
morning
and good morning to Vlad many mountain
towns here in the city of Nevadas this
morning look like this up to nine feet
of snow have fallen over the past week
three feet of snow in just the last 24
hours a single Square cubic foot of snow
wet snow weighs up to 20 pounds when you
multiply that by nine feet spread out
over the surface of an entire roof we're
talking about a potentially deadly
situation here police already confirming
one person died from the weight of this
snow on top of all that it is 27 degrees
here this morning and thousands of
people including here in this town
without power and stuck inside
in California it's been a winter of
discontent the season of storms has
relentlessly dumped round after round of
snow
with blizzard conditions overnight in
elevated communities dropping two to
three inches of snow every hour
[Music]
sheriff's deputies in Northern
California are using snowmobiles to
check on trapped residents after many
major roadways were shut down everyone
here is feeling completely stuck most of
the stores are running out of supplies
the gas stations appear out of gas the
storm has also turned deadly an 80 year
old woman was killed when her snow-laden
porch collapsed many in Southern
California's San Bernardino Mountains
have also been stranded County officials
declared a local emergency yesterday to
get state and federal help clearing
highways and neighborhoods I'm standing
in the middle of the road right now and
every time you take a step my foot goes
down about four feet one triple full at
a time Bruce Martz and his wife haven't
been able to leave their vacation home
in Lake Arrowhead for six days now this
is the real deal and there's a lot of
people in need up here it's just a
matter of who runs out of food first the
county says the snow it managed to plow
yesterday will be replaced by another
foot of snow by tomorrow and with all
that snowfall comes more heavy rain in
lower regions and the potential for
mudslides like this one which came
dangerously close to this home it's like
50 feet from the house right now we
gotta get to a hotel
and the snow continues to fall in
certain areas get this in Yosemite
National Park park ranger is confirming
some areas there getting 15 feet of snow
Interstate 80 a major thoroughfare here
in the Sierra Nevadas remains closed
today and officials are warning drivers
to not try to bypass road closures not
only the threat of snow on the ground
but the very real threat this morning of
potential Avalanches Gale
oh that's the last thing they need to
hear thank you Jonathan